heading up to September 11th in his book
the looming tower he's interviewed by
Arab American Institute founder and
president james Zogby al-qaeda and 911
tomorrow at three p.m. eastern on
afterwards in 1981 Washington Post
reporter John pomfret was an American
exchange student at China's nanjing
university in his new book chinese
lessons he uses the experience of five
former classmates to describe china's
cultural and economic transformations
this talk from the Milken Institute in
Santa Monica California is around an
hour ten minutes as you on behalf of the
Milken Institute and Mike Milken our
Chairman and Mike clouding our president
CEO unfortunately not able to be with us
today welcome to the Milken Institute
we're delighted to have you as you can
see we have a full house a matter of
fact within days of us sending out this
invitation we had a full house we had to
actually stop registration I think that
is a an indication certainly of the
interest in China and it's a testament
to the quality of our speaker today John
Pomfret studied china chinese history at
stanford university and he spent two
years at nanjing university as one of
the first groups of Americans to study
in that country as it moved in the
beginning beginning of its move from A
to talion therrien state to its to an
economic giant idiot that it is today
over the last two decades john has
returned twice as a professional
journalist to China and was an
eyewitness to events at gen'l'men Square
in 1989 in his last post he was the
Beijing bureau chief for The Washington
Post and today is the Post's Los Angeles
bureau chief on the occasion of his 20th
reunion of his Nanjing class John
decided to reacquaint himself with his
classmates in his new book
Chinese lessons five classmates and the
story of the new China is the story of
their own and of his cut of their
country's cultural and economic
transformation I don't know if you've
been reading the reviews today the wall
street journal had a review of his book
and Pulitzer prize-winning journalist
Ian Johnson had this to say of the book
at a time when so many books about China
are written from a distance their
authors having spent only a short time
in the country if any time at all thank
goodness for Chinese lessons and to that
i would add thank goodness that jon is
here today so without further ado please
welcome John pomfret I have a couple of
problems when I speak publicly one as
I'm almost always can't be a dissonant
my notes and I have a tendency sometimes
to bounce a little bit too much if I do
that I'm sorry but it's sort of the
Protestant soul man inside me I first
went to China in nineteen eighty as skip
said when I was 21 years old and it's
very easy for us to forget but China
then for most Americans was a forbidden
and a forbidding place in fact going to
China then for me was probably the
closest thing and actually for the many
of the Americans who went that we could
get to interplanetary travel without
joining nasa the things that struck me
about China then were absences for
example colors the countryside the
cities were two colors brown and grey
and the clothes people wore were also
two colors blue and green only the very
young kids were were outfitted jauntily
the economy of the country had been so
beggared by 30 years of Maoist economic
policy that the caloric intake of the
average Chinese in 1980 was equal to the
caloric intake of the average Chinese in
nineteen thirty at the Nanjing
University dining hall where I ate most
of my meals for meat we had pork fat
and for vegetables we had these tiny
green things called green garlic tips
which were highly fart inducing but that
was particularly perilous because I was
bunking with seven guys in a 10 by 15
foot room and we lived in Nanjing and
Nanjing being south of the Youngs a
river had no heating and so the windows
had to be closed during the winter I
played a lot of basketball and I was
struck by my teammates and we would
stand courtside and we would disrobe as
we got ready to play hoops and the
sweatshirt would come off a sweater
would come off shirts would come off
t-shirts would come up to reveal these
bodies that were just inches away from
African refugees at that time the per
capita GDP in China was three hundred
dollars a head so fast forward to today
the per capita gdp in China is over a
thousand dollars the caloric intake of
most Chinese in the cities is world
class and pot bellies which when I was a
kid in China where as rare as a panda
are now as commonplace as that Starbucks
Kentucky Fried chicken's and also the
McDonald's that line China's streets
China's economy has grown an average of
nine percent for the last 10 or so years
and its appetite for steel oil soy beans
timber have rocked world commodity
markets its military the people Zipporah
Liberation Army has embarked on a
massive defense spending spree they've
gotten double-digit defense spending
increases every year since 1989 except
for one and with that money they've
purchased world-class weaponry from the
Soviet from the former Soviet Union so
they have some remedy destroyers they
have su-27s you 33s and soon-to-be
su-35s from the soviet former Soviet
arsenal they have sunburn anti-ship
missiles with over there over the rate
over-the-horizon radar capability in
addition there's a new class of Chinese
nouveau riche that have emerged on the
world stage Cartier in 2004 had two
shops in all of China today it has 11
and by 2010 and estimates it will have
30 it also thinks that China will soon
overcome japan as its second biggest
market so in a sense the rise of China
as this very powerful military very
powerful you can't economy in a very
powerful political nation is almost
inevitable but for the next few minutes
what I'd like to talk about is that I
think that this rise is contingent on
China winning a series of lies what I
call bets that it's making on its future
some are very conscious wagers and
others aren't and some are long shots
but others are sure things but for China
to become the great nation that it
really wants to become for the 21st
century to become China's century it's
going to have to win the majority of
these bets the first bet is that by
reforming the economy first and leaving
political reform for later if ever by
doing that China will not face
ultimately a revolution to discuss this
I need to go a little bit back in time
to the events of 1989 because they're so
crucial to understanding today on the
evening of june third 1989 the people's
liberation army invaded beijing it was
one of these moments in Chinese history
where the rest of the world no matter
what they're doing sort of sits up and
pays attention about what's going on in
China the crackdown on the tenement
Square protests encapsulated by that
that young fellow who stood in front of
a tank for a few minutes and was
photographed by dozens of photographers
the image sent around the world was a
great an amazing moment and a very
tragic moment as well in Chinese history
three years later a moment of similar
importance in Chinese history also
happened but not too many people paid
attention to it and that was dunk shout
paying the same fellow who brought you
the 10 MN square crackdown spent his
spring festival holidays in southern
China the trip that dung took which was
known as the southern tour in the
Chinese propaganda was heralded by the
Chinese presses very similar to an
emperor going on a fact-finding mission
to the far reaches of his amp of his
realm but dung had a mission on that
trip and that mission is extremely
important to understanding China today
the mission was effectively to jumpstart
he
economic reforms that had been stalled
by a group of very conservative people
who had taken control of China's economy
and government since since 1989 dung in
speaking to officials in shen jen said
the hardliners in beijing were and I
quote just farting I think maybe he and
I may be shared the same dorm room or
something if you see to another one he
said if we don't reform or dead go
faster he told the people of shenzhen
and guangdong province dung strips
signaled the end for all time of Maoist
economic policy and it also signaled the
hashing out of the creation of a new
social contract a de facto social
contract between the Chinese state and
its people and what that social contract
basically laid out were it offered the
Chinese people three things that
effectively had been denied since
nineteen forty nine and offered them the
chance to get rich it offered them the
chance to eat again great food it
offered them the chance if they wanted
to to have lots of sex and the point is
that dung's trip did not just signal the
beginning of an economic explosion in
China it also catalyzed a social and a
sexual revolution which continues to
this day which is extremely important
the number of private businessman after
1992 skyrocketed and today more than
fifty percent of China's economy
arguably is in non-state hands but the
government also did something else it
backed off on its full court press that
it had on the personal lives of the
average Chinese before 1992 Chinese
people had to get state permission to
get married state permission to get
divorced ahead state had to get state
permission when they could have the own
their single child that's they get state
permission to go abroad to get a
passport the ads they'd get state
permission to move that to get state
permission to change jobs and slowly
since 92 all those permissions have
basically evaporated so while 1989
denied Chinese people the dream of
democracy if you will 1992 gave them
something in return it gave them
substantial personal freedom and for
people who had
lived for 30 years under to use the
cliche the jackboot of a totalitarian
Society it was a big thing in 1992
effectively marked the end of that
totalitarian Society in the beginning of
a new type of government in China sort
of an authoritarian political system so
this social contract has worked
extremely well for the past 17 years
remarkably well in China but the problem
now is the social contract that social
contract in China has begun to fray many
Chinese have embraced dung Xiaoping
mantra to get rich is glorious and
they've done extremely well but many
many more have lost out in this doggie
dog or to use the Chinese expression
many man form of capitalism which is now
very current in China these people have
are seeking often seeking redress to
their problems so they go to labor
unions but the problem is the labor
unions in China are run by the state and
often and only work for management they
also go to the courts but the courts are
run by the party and the courts often
work for management they also go to the
government with their complaints and the
government of course is run by the
Communist Party and usually in business
with management so it makes it very
difficult if you're a half not Chinese
person to take it anymore in the
countryside tens of millions of people
have been kicked off their land through
a alliance of businessmen and the party
who yen then use this land to create
things like condo developments or
housing projects or industrial
development zones or shopping malls in
the cities over 30 million people have
been fired from the jobs from
state-owned enterprises what happens is
then the former business managers will
strip the assets of the state-owned
enterprise and enrich them themselves
but never the average worker China's gap
between rich and poor is greater than
that of the United States now China
enthusiasts in the United States speak
and write volumes about how wonderful
China's education system is it does turn
out fifty thousand engineers a year but
we also have to remember that China's
education system is currently very much
cheating its poor people China devotes
only 2.1 percent of its gdp to education
that's all
a third of what we spend in the United
States and interesting it's half of what
they devote in India the gap between
rich and poor has sparked a lot of
social unrest China's Public Security
Bureau its Police Department reports an
increasing number of what it calls mass
incidents antisocial and mob violence
and public order disturbances this shows
a growing willingness of Chinese people
who are fed up and can't take it anymore
to take their grievances onto the street
now president who Jintao and premier
Premier Wen Jiabao have spoken about
their desire to narrow this gap recently
actually last year the Chinese
government banned all taxes in the
countryside they've also spoken out
against illegal land seizures but the
problem is that now in China the central
government does not have the authority
it used to have to affect change and in
addition when they banned taxes in the
countryside they didn't fund fully
programs that would make up for the loss
in tax revenue so what happens is that
local County Chiefs are being forced to
instead of having taxes they then
actually add fees on to the peasantry
which is effectively attacks and so the
peasants are still paying money to the
state whereas what one job I wanted them
to do is to stop taking money out of the
peasants pocket that's not happening so
the party right now is betting that it
will be able to grow itself out of these
problems out of this political problem
that it might have in the future the
problem is that what happens if China's
economy begins to slow down what happens
if the graphs which we always see in
China which always seemed to go up begin
the level off or actually start pointing
down so ultimately I might mind my sense
is that China's bet that it will can be
able to avoid political reform and
actually put it off forever and not
actually embrace it is a very big one
the second bet that china is making is
that it's going to get rich before it
gets old the last thirty years there
have been two very important demographic
trends in China
the first one is that life expectancy of
the average Chinese has grown from 63 to
70 the second one is the fertility rate
and Chinese women is dropped from 6.5 to
1.8 and what that means is that 35 years
ago for every one person in China over
60 there were six kids in 35 years if
these demographic trends continue and
there's no sense that they're not for
every two Chinese people over 60 there
will be one kid China's demographic
trends are actually much worse than
those in United States in 2004 eleven
percent of China population was over 60
by 2040 twenty-eight percent is expected
to be over 60 that's going to be higher
than the percentage of people over 60 in
the United States in 20-40 the US will
have 2.3 workers for everyone over 60
whereas China will only have two now the
reason why this is significant is that
China does not have safety net it does
not have a pension program it does not
have massive Medicaid and Medicare even
though we have these troubled programs
in America nonetheless we have them they
have nothing like that in fact the only
group of people in China who have a
pension system are people who work for
state-owned enterprises and those are
going out of business at an alarming
rate and they are not keeping up with
their pension commitments so how will
try to deal with this problem will it
begin to fund a huge pension program or
social security program for its people
that has Chinese economist worried that
putting billions of dollars into a
program like that will affect the
economy and if they affect the economy
they will increase unemployment and if
they increase unemployment Social sista
bility will then have a problem as well
a third demographic trend is also very
interesting to note and this is a
demographic trend that actually could
play with have an effect on social
stability the demographic trend is this
the Chinese people specifically in the
countryside favor boys over girls the
gender gap in some provinces now is 135
boys 200 girls the average usually is
105 boys 200 girls the Chinese used to
use infanticide as a way to deal with
this
by basically killing killing girl babies
they don't do that anymore what they do
is now sex-selective abortions this is
becoming very very popular with the use
of ultrasound machines which are
basically available in almost every
Chinese hospital technically it's
illegal for a Chinese doctor to tell a
couple what the sex of their the gender
of their child is but in China with a
little back sheesh you can get almost an
all the information you need this is an
enormous problem Chinese demographers
estimate that within 10 years to 20
years there will be effectively an army
of 40 million unmarried and potentially
unmarriageable Chinese men that has the
Public Security Bureau worried about
social stability and other issues as
well so China is betting somehow that
it's going to get rich before it gets
old I think it had better hurry up bet
number three is that as China gets rich
it's going to be able to grow itself out
of its environmental problems just a
couple of statistics seventy percent of
China's rivers and lakes are polluted 16
of the world's 20 most polluted cities
are in China 150 million people in China
drink water that actually makes them
sick it's not bad for their health it
actually makes them ill and air
pollution is blamed in China for forty
four hundred thousand x.x excess deaths
a year China's leaders do talk a lot
these days about the environmental
problems and they do seem to have a
commitment to cleaning up the
environment but again the issue is that
when given a choice between pushing the
economy forward and protecting the
environment they will always choose to
push the economy forward the reason
being is that the legitimacy the
Communist Party is rooted in a growing
economy if the economy begins to falter
the Communist Party has no other
legitimacy on which it can rest I'd like
to give you sort of a case in point from
my book about about the environmental
problems and the difficulty the Chinese
have had in dealing with the environment
the wye river is the third longest river
in China it's its most polluted it runs
sort of been through central China
through anime province and it ends
somewhere in Jiangsu province in the
1990s
dung Xiaoping zai dia that to get rich
is glorious Chinese along the river
started an enormous number of what they
call township and village enterprises
these were small steel mills small
chemical complexes paper mills cement
works and the area along that river
boomed it had used to be it used to used
to been an agricultural backwater but it
was booming because of these township
and village enterprises but none of them
use any pollution control so they dumped
effluent in the river and in the mid-90s
the environmentalist started to notice
these barge like collections of trash
effluent and pollution some is tall as
six feet high some as long as several
miles floating down the wye river people
near the river had to walk along the
river with their faces wrapped in a wet
towel so they wouldn't wretch because of
the smell the problems were enormous one
of my classmates went into business
around that time and his business was
extracting an enzyme from human urine of
which there's no shortage in China of
course and turny getting in sending it
down to Guangzhou where it was turned
into a medicine called euro kinase which
can be used for people having a heart
attack it's an anti clotting mechanism
I'm a pharmaceutical product and so my
classmate began use one city along the Y
River bumbu which was very gritty
industrial town sort of like Gary
Indiana in the middle of the Industrial
Revolution in America and he used the
people there too he collected urine from
public toilets there and one day he
brought his product down to Guangzhou to
sell it to the dealer and he went back
to his hotel and waited for the dealer
to call him up the dealer called him
called him up and he went over to the
hotel back to the guy's office and the
guy said I can't buy any of this product
I don't know what it is it's not the
enzyme and my classmate said well I
collected it from the people of bamboo
there should be no problem the guy said
I don't know what the problem is it's
just not good enough there's just I
don't actually don't even know what it
is so he took the stuff back my cosmic
took the stuff back and he had it
analyzed and it was laced through and
through with heavy metals
and effectively what's happened is that
the the pollution of the High River was
leeching through the water table into
the water of the people from bumbu and
coming out of in there p for several
weeks in the late 1990s the water and it
from the taps of bamboo ran black
literally at that point the central
government stood up and took notice
because turning on your tap and having
literally black water come out was a
little bit too much for them so they
sent down communist party work teams
which began to shut down all of the
factories along the river state Fiat all
of them were shut down paper mills
chemical complexes cement works we're
all shut down within several weeks the
problem with this type of operation is
they didn't really think the step
further how are you going to re-employ
these people no one wants to go back to
the life of being a farmer once you got
once once you got into the factory being
a farmer in China's relatively miserable
existence it's back-breaking the plots
are quite small and anyway the area
around where the factories were located
was also so polluted that there was no
way for them to return to agriculture so
the people along these rivers basically
had nothing to do unemployment went up
social stability went up what are the
local government officials decide to do
they began to slowly under the radar
reopen all the factories by 2004
according to Chung lady he has actually
a book out in United States which is a
fascinating book called will the water
sink the boat or will the boat sink the
water I can't remember how it goes he he
noted that about sixty percent of the
factors were open but 2005 when I went
down the river with my classmates one
hundred percent of the factors were
reopened and none of the pollution
controls were put on fascinating enough
when we were on the river ourselves we
again we're wrapping our faces in wet
cloths because the river smelled again
so badly so China's environmental bet
that it's going to be able to grow
itself out of its problems without
devoting billions of dollars to clean up
the mess throughout the country is
another one of the very very big one as
well a fourth bet that I'd like to talk
about is that in matters of
the spirit China is betting that a
nation can become a great one even if it
has no values even if it does not
believe in anything Chairman Mao did his
best up route traditional Chinese
culture in the Cultural Revolution he
pitted fathers against their sons
mothers against their daughters brothers
against sisters families against
families as part of his goal which was
to create a snit society where the
tattletale would become the hero of the
revolution Confucius excuse me confusion
belief and ancestors that ancestor
worship issue was replaced by the
loyalty to the great helmsman to the big
daddy of them all Chairman mal then in
1978 dung Xiaoping comes along he says
this ideology is ridiculous in fact all
ideology is ridiculous China from that
moment was seized in the pursuit of the
almighty dollar or the Almighty UN as
the case may be dung Xiaoping coined an
expression development above all which
is basically china's version of of it's
the economy stupid China embraced the
quest for dollars and its continued that
quest to this day but the problem is
that the search for something to believe
in still bedevils the Chinese now the
state is crackdown on organized religion
and so what the Chinese did was they
created one of their own which was
following gong just sort of a pastiche
of Buddhist views and Tai Chi type
exercises the problem there is the state
couldn't tolerate an organization
outside of its control it cracked down
on following gong killing hundreds
evangelical Christianity is also booming
in China there's an estimated 60 million
Chinese Christians the same number
there's also 16 million Chinese members
of the Chinese Communist Party but
evangelical Christianity doesn't really
have that much of a of a stake in China
and so there's problems there as well I
was interested as I wrote my book in
talking to many of my classmates they
said to me we have no beliefs we don't
believe in anything and I was interested
how these people lost their beliefs and
so I'd like to share finally with you
one story about how that happened in mid
to early May of 1989
was standing on a pedestrian cross way
over eight boulevards of highway looking
down and I was looking not at cars but i
was looking at people the whole thing
was full of more than a million people
marching towards 10 MN square they were
carrying banners filled with idea
idealism give us freedom give us
democracy down with corruption as I
stood on this pedestrian walkway a
friend of mine in the crowd noticed me
it was pretty easy to notice sort of a
tall goofy looking white guy and so she
walked up the walkway and she introduced
a friend of hers to me the guy was in
the uniform of the People's Liberation
Army and I was struck by him immediately
he had a firm handshake which is
relatively unusual in China and a
culture that's been bowing for centuries
it's good-looking guy quite strong and I
was really a conveyor from from from
from the get-go we became really good
friends and at that time I was a
reporter for The Washington Post and for
a Washington from me for the Associated
Press and for an AP reporter then to
have a contact within the military was a
godsend and even though this man officer
leo was only a composer in the military
nonetheless he had access to scuttlebutt
that I was desperate to hear so we
became fast friends on the morning of
May nineteenth nineteen eighty-nine he
called me in the early morning and said
hey I got something for you I think you
got to come out here in the afternoon
let's let's meet and so I drove out to
his compound with a friend of mine from
the AP and he got into our car we were
parked in the front of his compound and
he said I got a speech I want to read
you a speech and it was a speech from a
high-ranking communist party official in
the Beijing government the speech
basically said these protests have gone
on long enough it's time for us to crack
down we need to order the PLA around the
city we need to declare martial law that
was the first indication that martial
law was going to be declared the first
literally official confirmation but as i
sat in the back of the car as he read
this speech martial law people's
liberation army crackdown protests i
sort of began to relax for the first
time
since early April when the protests
began we've been working 20-hour days
I've been sleeping on the square we were
all pretty tired and I dozed off
basically I dozed through the greatest
scoop of my career and and never wrote a
word but the guys behind us weren't
dozing there was a van in which there
were Ministry of State Security people
with the directional mic and cameras and
they recorded everything the crackdown
happens and on june thirteenth i'm in
the off of the AP office diddling around
and i get a phone call ru palin that's
my Chinese name I said yes I'm officer
from a Beijing police departments
responsible for the activities of
foreigners in China you are ordered
immediately to come down to our precinct
house so I went down there and for the
next four hours I was interrogated about
my relationship with officer leo I was
not very cooperative and so at the end
of the four hours they brought out a
little blue folder and they read to me
they said penguin you are both
unfriendly and uncooperative we are
ordering you out of China we are here
buying expelling you from the People's
Republic of China you have three days to
leave that evening the expulsion with
the expulsion of a peasant of The Voice
of America led the Chinese news we were
two black hands of the of the anti-party
demonstrations that evening officer Leo
who was in custody the Ministry of State
Security was brought in to watch the
show they said you see that he's told us
everything you're sunk I returned to
china in 1998's birchy for the
washington post during that period of
time China was really feeling it's oats
often during press conferences china
central television station which is the
state-run media in china would pan to
the mug of a foreign correspondent who
was participating in the press
conference as if in a subtle way to say
you see the foreign Devils are coming to
us now as a very subtle way of telling
their people that this regime is getting
the imprimatur from every place around
the world even the Washington Post even
the New York Times my goodness during
one of those newscasts officer leo saw
me on TV so he got back in touch with me
I wanted to see him very badly but Alice
was extremely
10th ago meet him because this was a guy
whose incarceration I was directly
responsible for so there was a lot of
guilt I'd thought about him pretty much
every day since I was out of the country
and he was my chance to see him again to
find out what happened so I was I was
really curious but I also was extremely
uneasy so I get to his house parked my
car through walk up the three steps
through his three floor walk-up quite
slowly sort of shuffle and job a little
bit in front of the door and then I
finally ring the doorbell he opens it up
he's grown a beard he looks great suntan
and he's got the same warm handshake and
basically had to pull me into his
apartment but the story he told me was
really interesting and and this is it he
gets out of jail after two and a half
years of jail he hasn't been kicked out
of the PLA he still has his job he still
has his salary he's lost his wife she's
run off with another guy but even though
he has a salary and his job he's not
allowed to write music anymore the
political commissar comes by his house
every week and says have you changed
your thoughts and he says get on my face
week comes another week comes by the
political comment so have you changed
your thoughts and again the response is
saying get out of my face and after a
while officer they'll get set up with
this ridiculous type of back and forth
and so he just leaves town and where
does he go he goes to shen jen which at
the time in china was the last place
where these embers of the capitalist
style economic reforms it would soon
ignite the whole country we're still
burning he goes to shun jenna gets a job
building drywall in construction working
on construction projects funded by lots
of capital coming in from Hong Kong some
of his friends who were Hong Kong
Chinese who were also fellow composers
here that he's out of jail he's in shen
jen working construction so they go up
and they talked to his Foreman they say
give this guy a desk job we'll get him
some commissions you know give you ten
percent whatever so the foreman gives
him a desk job starts getting
commissions starts writing songs again
he starts getting more commissions the
Commission start to flood in he starts
doing extremely well then in the mid to
late 90s this nostalgia wave hits China
this nostalgia wave for the the music of
the 1950's of the music of the early
revolution in the music of the Cultural
Revolution
kind of a sort of a fonds goes asian
type of thing officer leo begins to ride
this wave and he begins to write these
mini operas sort of um I mean it's it's
it's a Versace or Liberace meets meets
Pete Seeger type of thing they're very
leftist but they're also extremely
kitschy but he does very well with these
things and starts to make a lot of money
he leaves the People's Liberation Army
he goes into business for himself
setting himself up as his own private
company and as the Chinese say he jumped
into the sea I went to a lot after we
met again I went to a lot of these shows
that he did and one in shen jen was
particularly amazing it was filled with
all these old communist guys in their
very fancy suits smoking their marbles
or their dunhill triple fives of their
panda cigarettes with their golfing
shoes and their wives in Armani or
Versace outfits tapping their feet to
these tunes like stick the Japanese
devil in the face yay for the revolution
and in one of them the guy comes out the
MC comes out and begins to talk about
the high tide of the revolution each
wave higher than the last and this is
expression the high tide of the
revolution each wave higher than last
goes on and on and on throughout the
whole show but I was counting on my
program how many times it was it was
being said and it turned out about 15 to
20 times and I was interested in the
high tide revolution because high tide
in Chinese means something else besides
high tide it also means orgasm and I was
sort of interested in that being
interested in orgasms but so at the end
of the show officer Leo and I go out for
a bite to eat and I'm like what's with
all the high tides and he laughs at me
he goes I'm just making fun of my
audience and I think that that sums up a
lot about how he lives his life he has a
very good life in China he's got two
apartments in Beijing he has a new wife
he has a ten-year-old boy who plays
piano with really extraordinary feeling
he's got a TV as big as my car but like
many chicks essel chinese and chinese in
the elite he's live
in a system that he despises but at the
same time he's also living in a system
that he doesn't think that he can live
without I think that Faustian bargain
has done something to the spirit of
officer leo for sure and it's also done
spirit sometimes something of the spirit
of China a little while back he wrote me
a note sort of summing up the lessons
that he'd learned over the last few
years of his life and it goes like this
said before I went to prison I was pure
hearted but inside they taught me how to
be tactful slick and diplomatic my
political commissar taught me how to lie
they taught me to be insincere so I
learned it and I learned it well and
that's how I play it now and I think
officer Lil really could be writing for
a whole generation so how can a country
that has lost its moral compass in a way
become a great nation that's another one
of China's big bets so above I've laid
out for bets about China's future I
think there's other bets that China's
making as well for example China's
betting that state mandated allocation
of capital is much smarter than a real
stock market China is also betting that
its banks which are technically
insolvent won't go belly up one day or
all at once it's also betting that its
model of producing more cheaper won't
turn in on it and in on itself and begin
to eat Chinese companies as well perhaps
China will overcome these bats I mean if
you think about it I mean when I first
went to China in nineteen eighty it was
really a dismal third world country and
when I last left China in 2005 it was in
some places sort of first world almost
new world type feel and indeed going to
China 1980 was definitely type of
interplanetary travel very much the past
going to China now to some places is
almost like interplanetary travel to the
future but I also wanted to leave you
filing with one cautionary tale a year
before I went to China for the first
time in 1979 a Harvard professor by the
name of Ezra Vogel wrote a book called
Japan is number one a couple years later
Mitsubishi the Japanese purchased
Rockefeller Center
in United States many people really had
a sense that we were soon to be in hock
to the Land of the Rising Sun well Japan
never became number one and perhaps
China won't either so with that we can
talk about other things take some
questions thank you very much
I wanted to bring awareness of a problem
that maybe some people aren't aware of
I've traveled to China many times and my
son was an English teacher there who was
murdered there last year this is his
photo Jewish started helping in the
fairfax area at age 7 delivering food to
the elderly my concern is and again I'm
not painting this picture of all of
China but with the push to teach English
to so many students before the Olympics
of 2008 while there's many legitimate
government-run schools that are doing a
great job there are also many English
sweat shops opening up at a rapid rate
and I think anyone can name someone they
know in their community that's gone to
China to teach and my son unfortunately
got involved with one of these people
embezzling money and who had a murdered
and it's very difficult to even have an
investigation I'm just wondering if in
many of your travels you've run into
that and what you're feeling is to to
help other future teachers avoid this
crime is a growing problem in China
right now again because of the growing
gap between rich and poor effectively
you could look at it as sort of small
scale class warfare where the have-nots
are going after the haves when I was in
Beijing it was quite popular for poor
people to to run a key along fancy cars
that were parked out in the open and so
after several months of this type of
thing happening no one parked their
fancy cars outside anymore unless their
driver was sitting in them so crime is a
really big growing problem an
embezzlement and corruption and Eve type
these types of issues in doing business
in China or very commonplace and so if
someone was going to be a teacher in
China I think you should go to a major
university or if not a major university
at least the b-level university that's
that's well-known you don't want to
really play too much with a fly-by-night
type of private college or private
school in the beginning now let's say
you go to Beijing University you teach
for a while and then you get to know
somebody then you learn to trust them at
that point then switching to another
private institution would make more
sense but you have to know that
first I think personal relations are
very important in China and doing due
diligence by the Internet is almost
impossible especially when you're so far
away with the explosive growth how
sustainable is the consumption of
Natural Resources oil and the
relationship with pollution over time
the the Chinese appetite for oil is
enormous and will be growing
substantially because right now in China
there's only 20 million cars we have
more than 200 million in United States
the Chinese plan to triple the number of
automobiles within the next 20 or so
years so since 1993 China has been a net
importer of oil that being said
currently china produces domestically
seventy percent of its own power because
it has such huge coal resources but
again that has the other unintended
consequences of being extremely
polluting so the quest for resources
upon the part of the Chinese government
and state-owned oil companies is
enormous they're going across the world
Venezuela Sudan Saudi Arabia Iran
everywhere looking for and also in
Central Asia Kazakhstan looking for a
very strong long-term contracts for
imported oil so that's a huge issue the
problem for the Chinese though is that
they don't have a navy that can that can
protect their sea lanes they're reliant
on the American 7th fleet to protect our
sea lions too to ensure imports of oil
so they want to build a pipeline from
kazakhstan but that's a huge and very
expensive proposition so that's an
interesting issue the whole resource
cooperation and competition over the
next couple of years
hi if China is a very ancient place and
they've been through cycles like this in
the past how has how has reformed come
to China in the past if you're I guess
your book but certainly your address you
know posits that some things might come
unglued here the things they may not
lose they may not win the bets so how
has reformed come before as maybe a
guide to how it would come this time the
mean we could take 76 you know the big
change in 76 78 the most recent major
upheaval that they have had in their
country as maybe an example it came as a
result effectively of a coup against
mouths wife and the people who supported
her and backed by the People's
Liberation Army and politicians like
them shout being in ya yin yang who
basically decided that the direction
China was taking was the wrong one but
change over the last 50 years in China
has been a fascinating combination of
internal party power struggles coupled
with activity on the street but the main
driver of that change has been internal
power struggles was in the Communist
Party and in fact from 1949 until today
the main source of instability in China
has been the Communist Party it hasn't
been I mean the reason why 10 MN square
happened was the party had could not
decide what to do so let these
demonstrations get bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger until
almost the whole structure fell over but
their main reason for the gentleman
square crackdown was because the party
didn't know which direction it was going
in jaldi young and other people were
fighting and so the party was
effectively couldn't could make up its
mind and so the main driver of change up
to this point in China save Communist
Chinese history has been internal party
faction fights now I think potentially
this problem could be huge for them as
it as people on this begin to take their
grievances to the street and increasing
larger numbers
whether people within the party will be
able to liaise with those people and use
those people to go after their enemies
is another question right now the party
is very United so I don't see any major
party changes happening for a while but
up to this point the main driver has
been internal parties power struggles
dung Xiaoping organised the economic
reform in China around four
modernizations can you tell us what
happened to those four modernizations
and is there a successor program to the
four modernizations well I mean the
accessor programs are basically written
into their five-year plans and we think
whenever we hear five-year plans
immediately we get dozy because it's
like oh no sort of common tern communism
everything so boring but actually the
five-year plans are still very important
to the central committee of the
communist party and to look at the
direction that it wants to take China
you should you should read to the best
of your ability to five-year plans and
the current five-year plan is actually
quite fascinating because it talks about
the gaps between rich and poor it talks
about the environmental problems so the
parties cognizant of these issues but
effectively that's become the inheritor
or that's the successor to the greater
four modernizations program that's not
talked about anymore but the theories
and the direction the Communist Party
wants to take are all embedded in the
five-year plans they're pretty they're
pretty worth reading does China have a
nuclear power industry that could
provide energy for its development so
that there's not such a great dependence
on coal or oil yes and actually it has
made a commitment over the last four or
five years to expand that power industry
substantially and there's American
technology there there's a lot of
friends technology there's also Russian
technology and they're building nuclear
power plants and they want to use that
as a way to decrease their reliance
potential reliance on foreign energy
sources
when I first went to China an 81 it was
hardly anything resembling an Internet
and the press was really muffled I think
today the growth of the Internet is
incredible and the press showing some
signs are a little bit of ingenuity and
tur pretation and so on wonder what your
assessment is of how the information
revolution has affected China how is
likely to in the next decade or two that
is a great question i mean the Chinese
have taken to the internet with with
amazing alacrity they've also taken to
short messaging and they they were short
text message messaging years before we
even knew what it was and actually it's
interesting because the Chinese language
is is is uniquely fitted to send short
text messages especially ancient Chinese
and so a lot of people have sort of
embraced ancient Chinese as a way to
send messages because in modern Chinese
two characters usually spell out a word
and in ancient Chinese you can use that
you can use that word with one character
so there's sort of it's a very
interesting way that they reimburse
their their old culture by sending short
text messages short text messages they
averaged about 150 billion a year
sending to each other whereas we're
somewhere in the tens of millions the
internet there's 120 some odd Chinese
people with with web accounts there's
fewer computers but people log on at
these web bars and it's a huge a huge
issue now the Chinese press is it freer
than it used to be to a certain extent
yes a lot of gossip columnist a lot of
issues for example like AIDS corruption
can be probed but if you write about
specific corrupt officials like the
mayor of some city you're going to go to
jail if you publish it so it's still
very tightly controlled and in fact it's
more tightly controlled now than it was
in the late 90s when i was there is the
correspondent but it's a huge change for
china now on the other hand of that
other side of that is that the Chinese
police have also been very good at
monitoring the internet there's 500
cities and China have internet Police
Bureau's and because of the structure of
the Internet in China they can monitor
almost everyone's email it will
and so as a result it's exactly but
actually probably even more because
because you when you when it you have an
email account in China you have to
register all sorts of very you can't for
example in America you can log on you go
to the Hilton Hotel and you can get out
of their website and no one knows who
you are but in China if you go to an
internet bar you have to register with
your Chinese ID number what computer
you're using at what time and that
information is always given to the
police especially when you go on to
restricted websites so they have much
closer ability to look at what their
people are doing then even the NSA does
here in some extent accident but I don't
even know about that but John we've seen
a dramatic amount of investment in China
by multinationals and private equity
firms there was a similar transformation
in Russia somewhat similar from command
economy to capitalist economy and
recently you've seen the Russian
government sort of try to you know
overtly expropriate assets how likely is
it for that to happen in China what do
you see is sort of the biggest risks to
private investing in China you know the
interesting thing with China is that the
economy in China is much more disparate
than the economy much less centralizing
the economy is in Russia and that in
China there are a large number a very
large number of relatively healthy
Chinese companies that want to do
business with the west minutes of
extremely but they're middle sized
companies and so in Russia generally
it's dominated by some major major
Russian firms which are centralized much
more centralized in the Chinese economy
is so that gives foreign investors huge
opportunities it also actually poses
some more risks in some ways the other
the other interesting thing is that the
Chinese government is much more open to
what they call greenfield investment
than Russia has been
and China you now and increasingly
important investors when they go to in
China have wholly owned foreign
enterprises 20 years ago those
enterprises were not allowed by the
Chinese government now they're actually
allowed in many ways encouraged
previously 10 or 15 years ago the
Chinese government would always demand
that you shared technology with them now
those demands in a variety and a variety
of areas are no longer demands they
don't make those amends anymore except
in things like automobile manufacturing
which because it's considered what they
call a key industry so in order to for
example for Volkswagen to make cars in
china it's gotta tell china how to make
cars but in a lots of other areas
especially even in high-tech electronics
and chip manufacturing the technology
does not need to be shared with the
chinese or as a result it's a much more
friendly environment for foreign
investors the risks the foreign
investment in china i think our
potential for polluted political change
and you can ask serious economic
downturn in china I think there's are
too serious risks but you know you could
have those have those risks in any in
any country but I think for the Chinese
government by caveat to say we're rina
lysing this product I don't think that's
going to happen I really don't because
they are moving towards a much more open
economy but they're doing in a
relatively slow pace and so they're very
and then the people who run China's
economy are very staid and sharp is this
men right now so I can't see that
happening many of the issues that you
discuss involve investing capital and
infrastructure I'm curious how does the
government decide which projects to
invest in what is their willingness I
know they don't have bonds and invest in
capital that way how does that process
work that process works by the communist
party meeting and hashing it out and
through a variety of things for example
there's a huge development project
projects I mean they're dozens happening
in the city of Chongqing used to be
known as chunking as in and 24 some odd
years ago that's that same type of model
happened in Shanghai which basically
created the shanghai skyline these are
effectively their government decisions
that we need to have a financial capital
put it in shanghai and then tens of
billions hundreds of billions
the dollars flow to that city we need to
create a major city in western China put
it in Chongqing put it in Chongqing and
tens of millions hundreds of billions of
dollars flow into challenging these are
decisions effectively made on made by
the central committee of the communist
party and there's lots of wrangling
because of course province X wants more
assets profits y months so there's a lot
of competition then that's how factions
are created and it depends on whose side
of the faction you are which would type
of benefits you'll get but it's worked
out among the Central Committee among
the ministries but mostly within the
party the Chinese people in general
don't have a belief system does the
Chinese government recognize this as a
problem and if so why don't they simply
teach a more friendly version communism
or no traditional Chinese velocities
like Confucianism or Taoism they've
actually begun to reimburse Confucianism
but top-down instructions to the masses
in China don't work as well as they used
to and people are a little fed up with
the government telling them what to
think people generally will accept the
government's line on issues of
international relations but when it
comes to what's happening domestically
in China for the government for example
for who Jintao which he has to say we
pursue a horn a harmonious society
that's the new kind of buzz word a
harmonious society which is basically
taking elements of Confucianism and
trying to merge them with modern-day
communism the average guy in the street
doesn't really take to that especially
when you have situations like this the
sort of the doyen of the school of
communism in the school of Confucianism
in China so one of the leaders of the
China's China's Academy of Social
Sciences study of Confucian Confucianism
and how Confucianism is relevant to
China was arrested in China last year
for running young Chinese girls to the
United States claiming they were they
were his wives so he was involved in
this kind of sex for visa type situation
so when a guy like that who's supposed
to be the main Confucian role model is
involved in sort of a sleazy sex for
visa type scam with the i ns
after him in the Chinese government
running after him it doesn't do too much
for the good name of old Confucius John
I'd like to if I could just I appreciate
the helicopter view of Chinese
civilization Chinese history and
politics I wanted to bring you back a
little bit to the book because my
understanding is of course it's anything
other than a helicopter view that it's
structured around you're telling I guess
an emblematic story of these five
classmates of yours and whose own
journeys over the last 25 years capture
some of these larger themes you've been
talking about so I'd like just have you
discuss a little bit about how the book
is structured who these characters are
and in broad detail what their lives how
the journeys they've traversed at the
end of my tour in China well near the
end of my tour I was I very much wanted
to write a book about China because I
had a lot of things I wanted to say
about China and effectively had two
choices one of them is sort of do of
greatest hits all my big really
interesting stories about China try to
put him into a book and throw an
overarching theme on top of it and hope
people would buy it and the other idea
was to go back and to hang out with the
people that I first got to know when I
first came to China and try to find out
what happened to them and so I did that
and I was welcomed by these people
because I was their classmate and they
gave me an extraordinary access into
their lives and so I wanted to write a
book about not about China but about the
Chinese because there are lots of books
about China their books about China the
coming conflict the China the coming
collapse of China China Inc China this
China that and I wanted to write a book
about what it has been like to to be
Chinese over the course of this amazing
historical road they've taken so I at
six there were 63 members of my class
who studied history at nanjing
university they started college in 78 a
year after the the tests were resumed
the college entrance examinations were
resumed and they graduated in 82 and
there were sixty three members of them
and of them of those 63 people I
interviewed about 50
and then I started to hang out with
fewer and fewer for longer and longer I
came a bit of a pain panty ask these
people but they were very very gracious
and the end I I came up with a woman who
worked for a state-owned enterprise as a
as a as an editor on a small magazine
and she had a very fascinating story
because she'd been through hell during
the close revolution and then when she
graduated from Nanjing University she
was assigned a job because then everyone
was assigned a job to Beijing which was
the best thing in the world that could
happen to anyone and she said I don't
want that job because I'm in love with
somebody and she married a guy for love
and she went to hoof a in anime province
which was a real dump and she went there
for love and and her story is for me a
really uplifting story about somebody
who in the face of the system which said
you must do this did that and I thought
that that was emblematic of what a lot
of Chinese people have done over the
course of the last 20 some odd years the
second guy was this guy mr. Joe who was
really a child of the earth he was very
poor when he was a kid party secretary
in his village had his thumb on my
friends head he was a Red Guard he beat
people he was a torturer a tormentor and
then he in turn was tormented by people
he got into the People's Liberation Army
after University and he finally junked
that and he became a businessman he
jumped into his into the sea as the
Chinese say and his I think story for me
was also emblematic of this this rust
towards capitalism another guy was a
dissident sort of a feckless character
he was caught in Italy during nineteen
eighty ninety LED demonstrations and
what happened to him was that he turned
into a sports reporter and a very good
one because China loves soccer and the
Chinese soccer team is really bad but
they love soccer and they love Italian
soccer and english premier league soccer
and he was based in Italy and even
though he was effectively persona non
grata for a while he was in Rome and
local Chinese newspapers found out that
he was in Rome and he started to send
faxes back of you know italy vs madonna
or anything like that he's gay
he went to he actually I will actually
went to a game with him my first
professional soccer match that I ever
attended you can see that was in New
York Mets fan and he did very well with
that and ultimately became a very
well-known Chinese sportswriter and they
gave him a nom de plume it'sit's shalini
which is Giovanni right in Chinese so he
and he was also a bit of a Romeo as well
and so there's that and another
character was a party guy and I wanted
to write about a doer in the party
because in the West most of the people
we read about when they're Chinese or
people that have had a hard time in
China people who have been fighting the
government and our freedom fighters and
dissidents and I wanted to write a bot
about a guy who was in the system who
was part of the system and part of the
distal this massively energetic very
forceful and if you go to China and you
look very successful Communist Party and
he gave me limited access but he gave me
enough that I could hook onto him and
write about him relatively and I think
relatively interestingly and then I
wrote about another character who
suffered a lot of problems in his life
but he also kind of made it through it
was it would basically it's a book about
the people who stayed behind the people
who didn't leave China 1982 the people
who stayed and I wanted to write about
them and they were wonderful enough to
let me do it and so that's the book 1979
China had what was called the first
abstract art exhibit but it wasn't very
abstract and they were having a hard
time with the architecture not wanting
to be part of the international school
not wanting to harken back to their own
history where are they now in the arts
what's going on after their long and
distinguished history and they are
Chinese let's let's talk first about
Chinese visual arts we can get to
architecture later and say Chinese
visual arts is is experiencing an
enormous explosion right now it's one of
the hip new places for international
collectors to go and buy art it has been
for about maybe 5-10 years one of the
problems with that though is that during
the 80s late 80s dissidents in China and
Chinese dissident painters were genuine
they had beliefs and they painted these
politically titillating paintings and
these sculptures of mal was a tier and
these things because they were trying to
express what it was like to live in
China now from the mid-90s until now
dissidents has become a commodity they
realized there's a good market for it in
America or in Europe because people
think it's hip and so they paint for
Western tastes they are technically very
good but in some ways it's sort of
devoid of the moral Center that they had
on the 80s and then they've lost during
this market period architecture in China
is fascinating it's a place where lots
of Western architects are being invited
to design massive buildings in the
center of Beijing right near tiananmen
square there is an enormous a dinosaur
egg shaped titanium bubble being built
by a great French architect who is
famous for like to char the chars de
Gaulle Airport and he's building this
massive opera and right in the middle of
Beijing it's right next to the Great
Hall of the People which is this
Stalinist monstrosity and that type of
stuff is happening all over the country
where you have these old Stalinist
buildings or these old beautiful
courtyard houses and then you have these
very modern things now the sad truth is
that the courtyard houses are being
demolished at a very dangerous and rapid
pace and in some parts of Beijing
actually where they have knocked down
old courtyard courtyard houses they've
built new ones that are just fancier and
richer but they've built them to look
old it almost reminds me of them an
incident long long time ago in the
Bosnian war where there was this old
bridge in mostar and the croat snide
this bridge was that built was built in
the sixth the fifth and 1589 the Krauts
blew the bridge down and the crotch
animal said don't worry we'll build it
and it will build it better we'll build
it older so
230 years ago a number of smart
individuals got together in wrote a
beautiful document which transform the
country and the continent of three
million people to the American miracle
miracle and what we are today 30 years
ago 1977 the Chinese monster started and
I fear 1.3 billion people are marching
with ever increasing speed but I don't
see the direction and therefore this
monster can crash any second my question
is is there a chance that somebody can
influence the leadership of the
Communist Party or you have any
influence or friends to convince them to
hire an American think tank like the
Milken Institute reason foundation other
would be good look for me this institute
and help them through this aimless
directionless system thank you I mean
unavailable no yeah I think that's a
great question i think the whole
question of the it's not really aimless
i mean it's it's it's it's like people
running away from a burning house and
they're running very quickly and they're
running very quickly into the future but
indeed as you said they don't quite know
where they're going and there's an
expression that dung dung Xiaoping used
to talk about all time it's it's more
just shut up well hello which means you
know crossing the river by feeling the
stones and that's very much what they're
doing right now and they themselves know
they don't quite know what the future is
going to hold for them because there's
no model for this type of transformation
the only model is the collapse of
communism and then this sort of new type
of political system and then then a
changed economy what they're attempting
to do is reform the economy first then
get into these other questions later now
I would argue that men
of them don't want to get into these
political questions later or again into
the question of what does China stand
for they don't want to do that and if
you see in their security council votes
and how they act in the international
community they always hold back they
always hold back they only will go
forward if it's a question that deals
with Taiwan or if it deals with for
example mercantilist interests money so
that's the thing they stand for now
whether they will ultimately stand for
something later i think is a really
important question which is one of the
reasons why i put that whole spiritual
element that bet as part of my talk and
i don't know the answer that question
either and I'm just as concerned in fact
even more concerned considering i own
property in Beijing as you are time for
John to sign books were going to take
two more questions one from each side
yeah John thanks for your query to poker
I hear what you said and also I was a
native tongue in native chinese i was
born in nanjing area i share my personal
observance honest insights with you
firstly the in china you always can see
a chaotic Pikachu all you know of China
is imbalanced and fraught with problems
and the promise but at the same time I
think a China can adapt to the change
and can overcome this challenge I based
my three observance versity is a China
is a centralized system is a critical
system it's not like USA is a
decentralized the smoke government mode
so it's the most powerful efficient
centralized system in the world it can
resolve any problems very efficient it's
just like they can a close down the
factories along that very well you one
week secondly I think a technology or
already changes me sometime like
internet like already facility the
chance of a signal transfer knowledge
and also you know facility you know the
kind of or you know a way to deal with
crisis in the future and the thirdly I
think China right now is not a totally
on society right now they are wrong by
five or seven people in the particular
euro know after ten days no one can make
you see in like 10 or more lastly i
think in China right now is about you
know if becoming Chinese becoming have
you having
beliefs there are about 20 million a
Christian Brothers right now in China
right now so i think the rising of
chinese great opportunity for USA and
under you know secondly I think that the
USA role is to help educated channel to
be responsible partying that in a global
escape I think this is my personal
opinion thank you thank you I have a
question what are the chances plans or
prospects for your book in any form to
appear in China directly published no
way pirated very high there's a guy in
Hong Kong and once the publisher and
Chinese language version and if that's
published and will be sold in China and
we're just kind of taking about you know
I'm it's kind of like a Hollywood movie
except you know I'm not going to make
any money here and I'm gonna make any
money in China either so change the
names of any of the people in a Chinese
version of the book um you know I
probably have to talk to them about it
and if they wanted me to I would